[Music]
welcome to the simple life of Malaysia I
have a leg behind me the beach right in
front of me even when I'm on holiday I
want to make sure that I stay active and
I wanted to get you moving remember a
short workout is better than no workout
so this 10 minute workout will work on
your butt muscles and all your ab
muscles
it's the summer season and we want to
look bikini body ready no equipment
needed only your home body weight so
let's get moving
each workout will be for 40 seconds long
with 20 seconds rest in between a cave
we want to really work on your butt and
also your abs so there will be a lot of
small pulses okay so get ready the first
workout will be crab walk with a narrow
squat so I wait - stay low point your
knees forward
give me a crab boat to the side with a
narrow squat good small and walk very
good so again this workout there will be
lots and lots of pulses so every time
you take a step to the side
pulse feel your butt muscles working
good so keep your chest open and look
ahead very good
stay low ok when you stay low that's
when you will be working on your glutes
and suck the belly in face forward to
work on your core very good keep going
small pulses you should feel your thighs
warming up nice last few more
that's one more and rest it up right so
cut the lunch to squat let's work on our
right leg first I want you to step
opposite side twist and give me a squat
so it's all about maintaining a low
position okay get ready shake your legs
a little bit and you will really feel it
on your left glutes right let's go twist
and lunch good very good
squat small so we're targeting one leg
at a time
feel your laughs vice and also your
laugh glutes working small pulses keep
going oh my god I can already feel it
burning nice keep going curtsy lunge to
squat very good well don't stop right
now don't come up right now oh no high
impact workout at all just small
movement but you are really targeting
specific muscles
and shake it out next let's work on the
right leg okay so again toes pointed
forward twist and work on the other side
shake it a little bit doing good and
let's stay low and do not come up five
more seconds three more seconds rest and
let's go stay low
twist and squat good now you're working
on your right leg
very good point your toes forward as you
cut the lunge twist and feel your abs
and your obliques working as well very
good
stay low feel your thighs for your
glutes and keep twisting you're halfway
there
crossover tiptoe crossover and good keep
going feel that burn and then energy in
your legs good push your butt back five
more seconds last few more give me a few
more and rest it out oh my God my thighs
shake it out okay the next one is going
to be a lunch with kickback so I went to
step forward take one leg back as you
come up
kickback squeeze your right glutes all
right so we're working again on one side
left lunch with the right glutes
squeezing and kicking ready let's go
down up down up good up squeeze the
gluts ask you come up that's when you
root you will really need to find your
balance good look straight ahead
focus on one point up and squeeze
squeeze and up oh those butt muscles
keep going we want to work on them and
grow them up and squeeze one leg at a
time
very good few more keeping these close
to the floor and shake it off shake it
off now let's work on the other side
okay so right leg forward left leg back
ready check it out a little bit focus on
Point has to come up target and work on
your car good step forward and give me a
reverse nice let's go down up down up
good whoo find your balance suck your
belly in find the strength with Venu
very good squeeze and hold good down
squeeze and hold very good squeeze and
home up keep your knees soft do not lock
them as you come up look at one point
and find a balance and engage your core
muscles good keep going keep going this
is your final glute workout before we
get on to the mat very good now let's
get down lie down I want you to get into
a bridge and a crunch okay so bend your
knees keep the 90 degrees keep your
heels close to your body all right so
right leg up
give me a bridge pose up and crunch and
bring your leg in okay that's it ready
let's go
Bridge pulse up and crunch good up
squeeze your glutes and squeeze your abs
very good gluts apps there you go glutes
and your abs the more you bring your leg
in the more you will feel on your apps
so showed us off the mat good keep going
point your toes now let's work on one
side to begin with and we will switch
after this keep going guys squeeze hold
it for one count at the top before you
lower your pad down up crunch shoulders
off the floor
very good rest for 20 seconds shake it
out and we want to work on the opposite
leg all right catch your breath
breathe in it's so nice out here right
now all right so right leg down left leg
up same thing
point your toes all the time and I want
to squeeze your right glute ready let's
go up squeeze and left leg in good
squeeze lovely in very good squeeze good
up and point if you're struggling you
can always start with a knee bend good
knee bend and extend eventually straight
and crunch up straight and crunch very
good so your hands to just be supporting
your head you shouldn't be pulling on
your neck or your head good up crunch up
crunch one more up and crunch all right
now back up let's get into a cat car
position and let's do don't his
sidekicks okay so I want you to bring
your body up all right hover and I want
to kick to your site bring it in
control and kick to your side that's it
ready let's go up suck in your belly
keep your side extent controlled small
movement control expand control and
extend okay by lifting your knees off
you won't make the workout harder
because you have to engage your abs and
also your cute even more beginners start
on your knee kick extend bring it in
cake and extend okay as you progress you
lift up kick squeeze bring it in
squeeze and down good extend control to
the side no to the back to the side very
good extend good point your toes put
your heels out and kick and rest it out
shake it a little bit all right stretch
out a little bit if you need to and we
want to work on the other leg good left
leg now Oh sweaty I'm starting to see my
sweater dripping on the mat all right
time to work on the left side let's go
up extend to the side out and extend
good squeeze in extend good kick your
heels out okay take your left heel out
and extend and keep your back flat as
much as you can
do not twist your body minimal hip
movement very good extend and pull it
back extend and pull good after we there
keep going
work when you show the muscles as well
push it out
good keep going do not drop your knees
right now okay give me a few more kick
okay stay strong stay strong kick
one last one kick and ha very very well
done that was one set of your workout ok
I hope you feel your glute muscles your
ab muscles remember guys the show work
is better than the workout take a short
break
breathe drink some water and if you have
the strength I challenge you to do this
entire video once more
alright so don't forget even if you're
on your Paulo day wherever you are a
short work is better than the workout
and you don't need any equipment your
body is your best equipment so utilize
this fully liked this video share this
video subscribe to my youtube channel
play this video on a daily basis and you
will see the difference and you'll feel
so much more energetic otherwise I'm
going to go to the beach right now
[Music]